The two solutions are negative 9 halves and positive 5. Nice algebraic thinking
for getting this one correct. We start by setting this equation equal to 0 by
subtracting 45 from both sides. Remember, for quadratic equations, we want to
get them in the form Ax squared plus Bx plus C. Where here, these numbers are
A, B and C. We want the other side of our equation to equal 0. Now we want to
find factors of A times C, or negative 90, that sum to negative one. Those
factors are negative 10 and postivie 9. We use these factors as the
coefficients to rewrite our middle term. Then we use factoring by grouping to
get these two factors. Next we set each factor equal to zero and solve for x.
For the first equation, we'll get x is equal to negative 9 halves and when we
set the second factor equal to 0, we'll get x is equal to positive 5. Finally
we write our solution set. Nice work if you got that correct.